in Venezuela cars don't depreciate
you could buy one today drive it for
five or six years and then sell it for
the same price you paid
and you can forget about gas at just
over six cents a gallon you can fill up
your tank for less than one US dollar
in Venezuela Banks offer loans for
plastic surgery taxi drivers earn higher
salaries than doctors
supermarkets are equipped with
fingerprint scanners
and some find it cheaper to live
year-round in luxury hotels than rent an
apartment
sponsored by brilliant learn math
science and computer science the
intuitive way with the link in the
description
in 2015 the country with the largest
proven oil reserves on Earth enough to
meet all of America's demand for 40
years ran out of toilet paper
hotels even ask guests to bring their
own
facing shortages of rice sugar milk and
shampoo on top of rolling blackouts 30
million people struggled to survive
without the most basic of basic Goods
Venezuela once the richest country in
Latin America was experiencing the worst
peacetime economic crisis in modern
history
a third of its entire economy
disappeared in one year alone the same
number as Ukraine in 2022
since then seven million people a
quarter of the entire population have
fled the country
this is the equivalent of the Great
Depression the hyperinflation of
Zimbabwe and the Syrian migrant crisis
all at the same time
and it's happening in a country with 300
billion barrels of oil
that's 11 times more than China and
nearly four times that of Russia a place
once referred to as more a gas station
than a country
this understates its Good Fortune
Venezuelan crude is practically begging
to be extracted
it's not far offshore like Norway's it's
not way up in the Arctic like Russia's
and it's not deep underground like
American shale
instead it just naturally bubbles to the
surface
and as the goal States prove one does
not need smart technocratic governance
liberal democracy or even remotely
favorable geography
oil and oil alone can turn the barren
Arabian Desert into the Swiss Alps
so how did Venezuela go so terribly
wrong
look
in 2013 a staggering 96 percent of
Venezuelan exports were related to
petroleum
it's not hard to see how oil prices
could make or break its economy
lower prices lower Revenue it's very
simple
less intuitive is the effect this has on
its currency
you see it's not just about how much
money it generates it's also about what
kind
when oil prices are high there's more
demand for Venezuela's currency the
bolovar so it appreciates
in the more one Bolivar is worth the
fewer you can get for the same dollar or
Euro or Yen making its exports more
expensive for the rest of the world
say for instance 10 boulevards were
worth one US dollar at this rate someone
in Florida could buy a pound of 20
Bolivar Venezuelan coffee for two USD
not bad
but then oil prices caused the Bolivar
to appreciate
that same pound of coffee now costs four
US dollars
through no fault of their own coffee
farmers are now half as globally
competitive
no this isn't necessarily as bad as it
sounds
when exports are effectively twice as
expensive Imports are effectively fifty
percent off
those 10 original bolivars are worth two
dollars not just one
it's no wonder virtually everything in
Venezuela is imported from appliances
and cars to simple things like food and
apparel even Bolivars themselves arrive
on 747s
all of this is to say in Venezuela the
highs are high
strong oil prices not only bring in
loads of cash but they also make foreign
Goods that much cheaper
in 1970 Venezuela had a higher per
capita GDP than either Spain or Greece
nearly 60 percent of the population was
middle class and the Concord flew direct
flights to Paris
another explosion of wealth came during
China's rise in the early 2000s
as demand for oil soared the country
even began importing doctors
but with such high highs come
extraordinarily low lows
because no smart politician withholds
riches from voters nothing is ever set
aside for a rainy day
and in the oil business there are always
rainy days
remember when oil prices fall the state
both loses revenue and the Imports
they've come to depend on become more
expensive
that's a brutal combination
those coffee Farmers from earlier go
bankrupt when oil prices are high
leaving Venezuela without domestic
producers of frankly anything when they
aren't
this cycle of boom and bust has been
going on since the first well was
drilled over a hundred years ago but
this latest crisis is especially
prolonged thanks to a potent mix of weak
oil prices and U.S sanctions imposed
after its president manipulated
elections
things got so bad that the country once
ran out of money to pay its supplier of
that money
so what was the government's solution
print more money
since 2007 the Central Bank of Venezuela
is no longer independent giving
politicians Direct Control of the money
supply
this to everyone's surprise led to
something called inflation
at first the government simply pretended
it wasn't happening refusing to release
the data
by the time it finally gave up the
charade in 2019 inflation was at 130
000 percent about 129
997 percent higher than its neighbor
Colombia
while taxi drivers can easily raise
their rates to adjust for inflation the
salaries of professionals were reduced
to nothing
no wonder such a high proportion of
migrants were doctors lawyers and
professors in Venezuela they were
effectively working for free
and when your savings today will surely
become worthless Tomorrow there's no
reason not to spend your paycheck
immediately
when they ran out of cash people simply
took out loans to buy everything from
TVs to plastic surgery
so the government took another page out
of the just print more money School of
economic thoughts price controls
after all if prices are too high why not
just impose a ceiling
in a sense it works state-run
supermarkets are cheap ridiculously
cheap
the question is is there anything inside
because prices are set well below Market
rates Shoppers are incentivized to buy
as much as they can get their hands on
anything you don't need can easily be
resold for twice as much across the
street or 20 times as much across the
border
it's estimated that up to 14 percent of
Venezuela's highly subsidized gas is
smuggled internationally
in 2015 lines outside grocery stores got
so long that everyone was assigned one
day of the week for shopping based on
the last digit of their national ID
to prevent the same person from using
their quota at multiple stores
fingerprint scanners were installed at
checkouts soldiers even patrolled the
aisles
here once again the government had a
solution
in Venezuela there is no one exchange
rate
the value of your money depends on who
you are
what could possibly go wrong
to encourage companies to import
essential goods and short supply for
example it offers a special favorable
exchange rate
the way it works is that a foreign
company say a Brazilian rice producer
wants to be paid in the global currency
of trade dollars
for a Venezuelan company to buy and
import that Rice therefore it has to
somehow get its hands on some USD
that's a problem because until recently
the government carefully restricted
access to foreign currency
unlike most countries you couldn't just
walk down to your neighborhood currency
exchange and trade some cash
huge multinational corporations like
Pepsi had to apply for the chance to
exchange their boulevards for US dollars
even when these applications were
accepted and they often weren't the
money might take months to arrive making
it hard for companies to import supplies
so few new cars entered the country for
example that used ones became highly
prized commodities
but it gets worse
the exchange rate offered by the
government wasn't the real value of the
boulevard
meaning the government might give you
one USD for five boulevards but nobody
else would give you a dollar for
anything less than say 50.
the official exchange rate was
essentially a government handout free
money for those smart or well connected
enough to get it
by approving these requests for dollars
politicians could reward their friends
and family
by rejecting them they could punish or
silence critics
it also opened the door to a different
more sophisticated form of Arbitrage
you might ask the government for
permission to exchange 5 million
Bolivars for 1 million US dollars to
help ease the shortage of car parts
but instead of using that money to
import a million dollars worth of tires
you might only import five hundred
thousand you could then sell the other
half million dollars on the black market
for far more than the 2.5 million
Bolivars you paid
and just like that you've created money
out of thin air
according to the government you're the
reason the system is broken
if only people bought from stores what
they needed and nothing more
if only people stopped exchanging
foreign currency
If Only They saved and invested rather
than spending everything they have
at the root of Venezuela's problems the
government claims our individual
opportunists
a similar argument is that the country
is plagued by a culture of selfish
consumption over prudent long-term
Investments
voters favor politicians who promise
handouts over those with a foresight to
save for the future
after Decades of gross mismanagement
Venezuelans have lost faith in the
collective power of the state
but if growing the pie is an unrealistic
pipe dream the only rational response is
to fight for your and your family's
slice
as the world enters a period of
financial tightening and possibly even
recession today's sponsor brilliant.org
can help us learn from Venezuela by
investing in our education and
diversifying our skill sets
when times are tough people invest in
themselves after the 2008 recession U.S
college enrollment increased by about
two and a half million
what I love about brilliant the
interactive way to learn math science
and computer science is that it offers
the perfect balance of structure and
freedom I want the ability to smoothly
move between subjects from biology to
programming to physics for example while
being guided through each interactive
lesson
if you're watching this video you're
already a curious self-motivated learner
Brilliance lessons on topics like neural
networks calculus and my personal
favorite game theory can help you take
your learning to the next level
click the link on screen now or in the
description to sign up for a free 30-day
trial the first 200 people will also get
20 off their annual subscription
go pick whatever interests you most and
start learning today